I want you to panic around the year 2030
we will be in a position where we set
off an irreversible chain reaction that
will most likely lead to the end of our
civilization as we know it if there's
one consistent message coming from
activists and politicians pushing the
green New Deal and massive new subsidies
for renewable energy it's that if we
don't take radical action now life on
Earth as we know it will soon be
irreversibly destroyed the world is
going to end in 12 years if we don't
address climate change the claim is that
time is running out and science tells us
that how we act or failed act in the
next 12 years will determine the very
livability of our planet this
fear-mongering is flat-out misleading
and the findings of the scientists
studying global warming don't support
such alarmist claims according to the
new book apocalypse never but you're a
radical new kind of environmentalists
because you're very well clothed the
book argues that deforestation and
deaths from extreme weather are actually
declining and concerns about
environmental damage from plastics are
fundamentally misplaced Shellenberger
who began his career as an advocate for
more government spending on wind and
solar was eventually disillusioned after
witnessing the failure of subsidies to
fix the inherent drawbacks of renewables
named a hero of the environment by Time
magazine in 2008 Shellenberger is an
expert reviewer for the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change he also appeared in the 2013
documentary Pandora's promise which was
shown at Sundance
and featured several prominent
environmentalists who have come around
to see the virtues of nuclear power it
really took us getting clear about how
big the gap was between fossil fuels and
renewables for us to take a second look
at nuclear coal natural gas fracking and
nukes you're my kind of liberal I
interviewed Shellenberger / zoom about
his new book and why he believes that
environmentalism
has become a replacement for religion in
an increasingly secular world michael
Shellenberger thanks for talking to
Reason thanks for having me so your book
is apocalypse never subtitled why
environmental alarmism hurts us all give
us the give me the elevator pitch of the
book I mean the elevator pitch of the
book is that everything they told us
about the environment is wrong often
it's the opposite of what they said
climate change is real but it's not the
end of the world it's not even our most
important environmental problem poverty
under development bad government are the
biggest factors driving environmental
degradation the same factors behind
poverty and disease and all the things
we're familiar with but more proximate
problems that are much more serious in
my view is the continued use of wood as
fuel by a 1 to 2 billion people in the
when are you building people in the
world
the overeating of wild animals in
general certainly wild fish the oceans
are in much worse shape and many people
realize but just just the kind of
poverty that pushes people into forests
to farm and use wood as fuel and eat
wild animals are really underappreciated
threats and the solutions are
industrialization and urbanization
solutions are moving away from
renewables towards fossil fuels and
eventually towards nuclear which is
obviously the best form of energy and
that that trajectory the physical
hierarchy of energy and the moral
hierarchy are just perfectly overlap
it's not I don't know any other
discipline or any other science that
shows this so clearly that one's life is
deeply improved by moving from wood to
fossil energy and then one's life is
it's further improved by becoming French
and getting most of your electricity
from nuclear that's a higher that's a
bold claim to say that we need to become
French in order to improve the future or
to have a future but let's start you
know there's a lot of claims there and I
want to work through some of them the
book is and I'll congratulate you up
front it is I mean it's both kind of a
mem
or but it's also a policy book and and
you do a really great job of blending
them your personal story is really
interesting because you are you are an
environmentalist can you talk a bit
about why you are interested in
preserving or you know improving the
environment and how that seems out of
earlier political commitments yeah but
basically some of the punchline to the
book is that our love of nature is
irrational there's no there's no
justification and I criticize
conservationists for somehow suggesting
that the continued existence of yellow
eyed penguins or mountain gorillas are
somehow important to human civilization
that those species went extinct that
somehow we'd be like a Jenga puzzle and
then the human civilization would crash
down suddenly we wouldn't have roads and
electrical systems and sewage systems
and whatever interests ridiculous it's
there's no mechanism for any of it and
that the reason that we want to save
these species is the same you know one
might say it's the same reason that we
we preserved and go paintings or or it's
the same reason that we you know you
know protect old churches or so it's a
preference it you know it's a preference
that we have so that of course you can
say that you can say its aesthetic you
can say its spiritual you can it's all
those refines to me as an environmental
activist now we were saving redwood
trees we never had did we here's our
strategy to save redwood trees was like
was like here's a photo of ancient
redwoods don't you want to save them it
wasn't we must save these redwoods
because if we don't then you know the
apocalypse will come and you know so you
how do we get to the end is near and so
that that traces back through the birth
of what we call environmentalism which
is really the marriage of Malthusian ISM
and and socialism hmm
well can I ask to dilate a little bit on
this the kind of preference question
early conservationists I guess more than
environmentalists or even
preservationist would often talk about
going into the woods and of course this
happens after
kind of industrial as industrialization
a second place but you go to the woods
to commune with nature and that that's a
powerful feeling and a meaning that's
that's kind of where you're talking
about the the preference for keeping
nature going is there how does that then
get yet yolk to Malthusian ISM and a
kind of an apocalyptic alarmism about
the end of you know the last mountaintop
or the last tree something like that
great well so there's sort of two
reversals that occur and the first
reversal is that the woods go from being
a place of danger and criminality to
that have to be conquered before God's
plan you know in Europe United States to
something that is beautiful and sacred
and special so that occurs you know at
least in Europe and what's called the
early modern period between 16th and
18th centuries and of course it occurs
after we start living in cities run you
know so you only appreciate the thing
after you're not the American Indian was
never so beloved as when he was no
longer a threat right to fright to your
people yeah you got it exactly so
so that's the first reversal and then we
get this period of sort of conservation
called aesthetic for spiritual doesn't
matter which lasts until about World War
two and so after World War two
there is a very powerful Malthusian
Drive I would say by elites in the West
particularly in the anglo-american
countries but it spreads throughout
Europe and it attaches itself to a bunch
of conservation concerns and it does
that in a bunch of different ways but
for the most part conservationists in
America in the United States and and
really probably in Europe as well that
we look at mostly I spend most time in
California was the conservationists were
pro-nuclear Pro economic growth Pro
people Pro cities they even said things
like you have to have a lot of cheap
energy to just protect nature to just
have nature
nature takes a lot of work you have to
you have to bat you have to have the
boundaries you I talked about in Congo
you know you talk to people and like how
is your life and his interview and
what's going on around here and they're
like hey or what do you always know
because you're big tall white guy they
know why you're there you're there to be
at the park and they go can you ask the
park director to put electric wire
around the park is the wild animals be
beating my crops right so that reality
of course still exists in really poor
countries but but managing nature turns
out to be very expensive and of course
there's opportunity cost loss but but
it's a it's an amazing thing if I can
just interject I know at in the early
60s when students for a Democratic
Society and their founding documents
Port Huron Statement and the young
Americans for freedom their conservative
counterpart that was founded by William
F Buckley and a couple of other
conservatives each of their manifestos
they take they assume nuclear power and
essentially free unlimited non-polluting
energy you know and that was you know in
in the early 60s that's what we were
looking forward to obviously it didn't
work out that way yeah I mean the Port
Huron Statement is so interesting
because of course it's like small
modular nuclear reactors parents suburbs
yeah because people had a thief at that
point they still thought the cities are
these monster cities I think that was
the language they used right monster
cities and them rather than live in
suburbs powered by nuclear well today
it's the exact opposite now now
environmentalist want to have cities but
powered by renewables and we also I show
why that's physically not going to work
for inherent power density reasons but
nonetheless you get to this these
humanistic you know greatest generation
conservationists who are overthrown in
the Sierra Club elsewhere too but we
focus on this focus at such a pivotal or
organization and they're thrown by the
Malthusian who are anti-nuclear whereas
the earlier conservationists are pro
nuclear and so the I unwrapped me a long
time it took me many years to get to the
bottom of what that was about where is
it you say arrived is it partly that
nuclear I mean talk a little bit about
how nuclear went from being the savior
of kind of the jet age or whatever to
being you know the ultimate thing that
we had to avoid was it and I mean you
talk about it at length in the book but
is it a kind of transference from
nuclear power to nuclear weapons and
nuclear weapons obviously you know her
Oshima and Nagasaki are the things to be
avoided we're you know in the post-world
War two ERA and through the 60s we're
living you know you know you know 15
minutes from the end of humanity and all
of that kind of stuff is that what made
nuclear energy such a pariah because I
know people like Stewart Brand the Whole
Earth Catalog founder merry prankster
you know important figure in the
development of personal computing as a
concept and a technology is was always
Pro nuclear but that went missing in the
in counterculture years right well just
on the case of Stuart he changed his
mind around 2009 and that was why I
changed my mind so he only changed his
mind very much okay yeah I mean I think
the the short version is that I see two
big factors animating anti-nuclear
ideology really starting to more
strongly in the 60s and it was first
just the true the truly shocking nature
of the bomb and the truly terrifying
nature of the bomb is is real and I
think some people feared it and he did
it for some ideological reasons but
there is some independent just the bomb
is a very serious invention the second
is the Malthusian ISM which is that the
problem that nuclear energy poses to
mullahs who want to control society and
restrict growth and do all the things
that we know what the people that call
themselves environmentalist want to do
it's threatened by nuclear energy
because nuclear energy means you have
infinite energy infinite fresh water
infinite fertilizer and I means you have
infinite food so nuclear eliminates
resource scarcity now how much resource
scarcity really was there before nuclear
yeah I mean it wasn't really wasn't like
we were ever really running out of
energy we now know we weren't running
out of oil or gas or coal or any of that
so that wasn't really real necessarily
but nonetheless
I think I document basically a reaction
to nuclear by Malthusian that I think is
clearly motivated by a fear that
basically this human cancer the in their
view the human virus we have to cut off
its power source
that was always the idea and again I
think it's more irrational than rational
sometimes these guys don't really pull
it apart and you're right about the
transference or I don't know
transferences I'm oppression use that
words has some recycling analytical
media but um displacement I think is the
word I use and we use in the book which
is that the fear displaces from the bomb
onto the power plant and that's true
although it's worth noting that it's not
something universally true it's true
among people who are on the left
not just the radical left either but
really this is often just mainstream
liberals and I think this comes from the
kind of old conte interview I didn't get
into it in the book necessarily but this
desire that human reason be the thing
that ends war not a technical fix which
what degree gets confusing very quickly
because you know you mentioned France
France supplies a large percentage of a
vast majority of its electricity needs
via nuclear power plants and in Europe
nuclear power seems more you know it's
more acceptable nuclear weapons
definitely not in the United States
nuclear what you know nuclear power is
pretty verboten you know is it is is
there a consistent threat or is is that
it's Malthusian ism and a dislike of of
a post-scarcity world and it just takes
different forms depending on the social
or political context yeah for sure I
mean I think that countries that have
the bomb are more comfortable with
nuclear and and in fact I think that I
think it's I've been it's not in the
book because I didn't quite have the
argument but I've been looking at
whether or not it could be that Japan
and Germany are uniquely anti-nuclear
because they they weren't allowed to
have it and they would like to level the
playing field plus I think there's some
pride and I mean look it's the best
weapon and obviously it's the best
weapon and Japan and Germany as anyway
so anytime there knows these are the
these are people that are deeply
committed to excellence and have deep
pride in doing the best of everything in
here they are denied the best veteran
hmm
before we get to the apocalyptic turn
because that's really what you you know
what's your book you know in its title
its apocalypse never you're confronting
that that's certainly the the
contemporary political discourse talk a
little bit about how you individually
grew to be an environmentalist and you
know why it matters to you I mean yes so
for me he you know just probably boring
like everybody my parents took me
camping a lot so we really loved being
out I loved nature you know and and they
were sort of I think my mom was still
Christian my dad was more post Christian
but death but out of a the Mennonite
tradition which is a pacifist anti
statist libertarian tradition by the way
right yeah I remote so I mean I'm happy
to see wearing buttons you've you've
gotten past that right it's progress
yeah very basic morality I never
believed I never I never I was never
Malthusian you know I just was never and
people would say there's too many people
in the world and always struck me as
racist because I was it wasn't I knew
they would beg no no and of course
there's too many you know rich white
people too and you'd always be kind of
like yeah but seems like you're always
it seems like all the sterilization
camps are in India you know it's like
doesn't seem like this is evenly
distributed concern but I was definitely
had more apocalyptic view and you know I
and I traced that in some ways to just
the bomb I mean I when I was I'm a gen
Xer I don't know I was born at 71 so by
1980 the the movie the day after I think
is 1983 so I was like 12 and this movie
they the ABC encourages parents to watch
this movie with their children and it
just like whatever you know 15 minutes
in it's just I mean and they show the
classrooms of children being carbonized
right you know so schools
you know that so you know so that was
really there in my certainly my dad was
more left-wing than my mom I read
Chomsky it like 17 and went in the
garage WA at 17 to work you know help
the Sandinistas and so I think the
apocalypticism also comes from socialism
or Marxism a bit too which is a kind of
view that you know of course there will
be this becoming of the kingdom of
heaven except for the communism or
socialism in the transition phase so I
had all of that you know I think there
was a bunch of things I mean in the book
I talk about just living with small
farmers and trying to be a revolutionary
socialist with small farmers he
discovers small farmers are like they're
not on board necessarily with
collectivization they they've got their
own farm you know they don't really even
want their brother telling them how to
how to do it you know that was a big
deal
seeing kind of the difference between
first world problems and thermal
problems which most people never
experienced in poor countries had a big
impact and it just became clear that
like a lot of environmentalists were
just putting nature ahead of lifting
people out of poverty and that that was
unethical and in fact the humans had to
always come first because otherwise you
know bad things happen and bad things
are justified and so I think they'll you
know and then I think another big moment
was just changing my mind about nuclear
and once once you could change your mind
about nuclear you can't go there's an
aha moment it goes oh so we're gonna
have to spread all this these crappy
renewables all over our deserts and for
us we don't have to grind up all this
nature for climate change you just have
nuclear power plants and once you
understand how power density works and
that it's good to move up the energy
ladder from wood and dung to coal to oil
to natural gas to uranium and that
industrial intensified agriculture
produces more food on less lands there's
kind of a picture that you get and it
was that picture that I had and it just
took a while to be able to actually turn
into the book let's talk about
contemporary alarmism in October and
these are quotes that are in the book
apocalypse never October 2018
grete tunberg or rather in 2019 in
October of 2018 a UN IPCC report comes
out which was widely kind of
misinterpreted to say we have 12 years
left grete tunberg in 2019 sense I want
you to panic about the coming the
imminent end of the world alexandria kzo
Cortes who was pushing the green New
Deal along with Senator Martin O'Malley
a Democrat from Massachusetts or
Maryland but she says the world is going
to end in 12 years if we don't address
climate change they're wrong how how can
you according to you they're wrong
what is the brief argument of how wrong
they are so the the two most important
things anybody needs to know about
climate change are that deaths from
natural disasters have declined 90% over
the last hundred years they've defined
80 percent over the last 40 years
including in very poor countries we
should be celebrating this like every
day that we tiny amounts that people are
swept away and in floods and hurricanes
and cyclones and killed there it's just
great news and then the other thing is
that carbon emissions have peaked in
rich countries they're going to peak in
poor countries in the next 10 20 years
maybe most some people think it peaked
already I don't but and so we're
probably most likely going to be come in
around 3 degrees increase in
temperatures globally over
pre-industrial levels you know any
increase in temperature does create
changes to how we've created our society
and what the habitats that we've set
aside for animals are so any increase in
temperatures does create problems there
are benefits to but it definitely
creates more problems so you don't want
to have higher temperatures if you can
avoid them all else being equal but you
know the guy that won the Nobel Prize
for economics on climate change the Yale
University professor William Nordhaus is
the optimal level for balancing cost and
benefits was four degrees so now three
run hit three degrees it's not the end
of the world again most literally
literally and figuratively not the end
of the world there is yeah and so I open
that first I'm going to publish it I'm
just gonna give away the first chapter I
think
my publisher just give away the first
chapter and I wanted to I go through
that evidence that you described and
then I say does any of that sound like
the end of the world let's go to the end
of the world and see what life is
actually like there and if you go to the
Congo the difference between the Congo
and my Helmand Berkley is that we have
like when the rain floods down my
hillside here we have a flood control
system I make sure my house is not
washed away they don't have that in the
Congo
they don't have electrical grid that
functions properly I do there's nothing
in any climate scenario that's going to
basically wipe out our roads and
electrical systems and sewage systems or
flow control systems and yet that's the
way that the the way that climate change
is described in these apocalyptic
scenarios which you can't find in
anything in the IPCC
IPCC doesn't even suggest that that we I
mean I think I've been trying to I've
been looking at this question of could
you ever say that anybody that you think
anybody will die I think I can safely
say nobody should die from climate
change I don't see a scenario where that
death toll that's declined from
disasters will go up now this is let me
make a point on this because I think
it's important I'm gonna write something
about this people who say climate change
is making disasters worse are either
deliberately misleading you completely
ignorant or they are using a definition
of disasters that the IPCC and
scientists don't use a hurricane on its
own is not a disaster what a disaster is
the corny IPCC is the effect of the
hurricane on deaths and costs people on
whatever that's the interaction between
the weather event and thing so I'm
having I'm actually I've been going talk
and trying to get the scientists to tell
me how she's claiming that cloud making
disaster is worse when how would you be
able to claim that if the deaths from
disasters are going down you'd have to
sort of imagine that they would have
gone down more if you had a temperature
increase deaths are going down even
though we are we have developed and we'd
everybody around the globe have
developed much more along coastlines
along places that are more likely to
have extreme weather events
yeah they experience like a 90 years
have even higher percent decline in
deaths from cyclones and the Indian base
and just by have mean better weather
because of it they're better predicted
and better able to predict weather and
then they have storm shelters it's super
low costs like really it wasn't so in
one hand you kind of got what were more
wealthy so we're more protected for
natural disasters which is true but some
of it's just cheap stuff but I mean I'm
kind of like I can't figure out if you
kind of go hurricanes are getting a
little bit more severe the fire seasons
a bit longer
it's just outweighed by other factors
you know so in the fires I point out
that it's it's the build-up of wood fuel
and forests and it's building houses
near forests that explain all of the
increase in fuel in fire frequency and
severity in the case of floods it's
whether you have a flood control system
or not I mean the new york times has
been running these news stories like
hyping flood thread and you're kind of
like well so then we'll make our flood
systems better I mean it's not like a
pot I mean it's not like somehow we're
all gonna be flooded because of climate
change and they make it sound almost
biblical in the in the in the in the
threat it poses as opposed to fairly
modest changes that were very evil
easily especially in rich countries able
to adapt to and so I mean is is the
equation for you as as simple and or as
direct rather as if you care about
people the good news is that fewer
people are dying from weather fewer
people are dying from pollution or
environmental degradation as we're
getting better at that and the way to
kind of supercharge all of that is to
increase general wealth I mean we should
I mean there's so many reasons to
increase wealth
so obviously that should be a major goal
economic growth should be a it is and it
already is of course at the highest
priority but you basically see the what
you get with the Malthusian left is they
say we have to do this all this I mean
they just the Democrats put out another
terrible Oh just a mass of bad spending
on climate stuff that doesn't first of
all most
it doesn't actually reduce emissions
doesn't have anything to do with carbon
emissions jobs programs and all the
stuff I mean some of it might be fine I
mean I might be fine with some I'm not
even saying it's all bad I'm just saying
it's not about climate change and a lot
of the emphasis in terms of renewables i
point out is is that precisely because
renewables make energy expensive that's
that was the that was not a bug that was
a feature of renewables as it's always
been imagined in every green new deal so
we and the idea there is if it's more
expensive you use less of it yeah it's a
very crude model basically making energy
more scarce and slowing down this virus
of growth it's just a D growth anti
growth agenda masquerading itself in
green clothing in a variety of ways
that's why I mean the watermelon that
gets said sometimes I think I'm the
libertarian front you know people see
greens as just watermelons only so that
became Reena green on the outside and
red communists no certainly no Marx Marx
there's an anti growth quality here that
wasn't either so explicit or wasn't
really center central to what Marxism
and socialism right we're supposedly
about yeah quite I mean that Marxism was
also trying to get to a post-scarcity
world and it's I mean it's it's fast
hiding that kind of the modern
environmental movement is really about
intensifying scarcity right yeah so it's
about I basically the book is in you
know it's in three that I don't have it
broken into three parts in the book but
basically the first third is everything
you've been told about the government is
wrong it's just a debunking of climate
deforestation plastic straws species
extinctions the second third is how do
humans actually save the natural
environment like in the real world how
did we save the whales
you know that's urbanization
industrialization substitution you know
we save sea turtles by not making
glasses out of their shells anymore
we use plastics and then the last third
is like how if environmental problems
are manageable if many of the trends are
going in the right there
erection if there's really no there's no
like scientific basis for imagining some
catastrophic events from climate change
what's going on what is this about and
so I basically just summarized it as
money power and religion and while I
think money and power are really
important obviously I wrote whole
chapters on them I think independent
factors behind this I think this is at
bottom this is people constructing an
alternative religion so this is because
of the general secularization of the
world we still have a religious impulse
and it's being rout rooted in a kind of
transcendental but symbolic love of
nature yeah and the problem with it is
that it doesn't acknowledge it in other
words if you're if I'm if I'm at you and
you're a Christian or a Muslim or
whatever and we're like I'm a Jew I'm a
Christian almost let's Who I am
but in and I'm into my religion and then
I have science and you know most
religious people very few don't very few
words really my religion and I've got my
science and then there's kind of a sign
and there's sort of two different my go
to church on a church or my when I'm
reading IPCC reports or something else
environmentalists they're there because
they don't think that they're in the
grip of a religion they start treating
nature as a new God they start treating
science as a new religion and that's
when things just go absolutely bonkers
and problematic let's let me ask you to
work through kind of how do you convert
is the wrong word but how do you engage
somebody constructively if they are kind
of thinking religiously without
acknowledging it and to go back to
renewables you know it's interesting to
hear you talk about how part of the
whole point of renewables was to
increase the cost of energy so that even
if it wasn't destroying you know even if
we weren't sucking oil out of the earth
and you know and ruining things that way
we have renewable energy but it's going
to be more expensive so even though it
doesn't despoil the environment we use
less of it can you quickly kind of
sketch is the problem with renewables
now that they are too expensive compared
to other alternatives or is it that they
don't work at scale or is it
combination of both of those so think of
it this way that there's basically you
know renewables are for you know
pre-industrial subsistence farming
societies there are low energy density
it's woods sunlight water wind they're
all very low energy density fuels or
flows fossil fuels are much bigger
increases in energy density they're what
allow us to have cities you can't have
renewable powered cities we did try we
had horse-drawn carriages and you had
horse species everywhere and disease and
all sorts of problems
so with electricity then also you can
have elevators and the buildings can go
higher until you get to nuclear where
really you completely D materialized
your power source so the problem with
renewables is just it's just physics
you know this Michael Moore movie which
got all this controversy which documents
the big environmental problems of
renewables they document the big of all
problems renewables but then they kind
of suggest that it's because of
capitalism as though like a solar farm
wouldn't require for higher times more
land in a socialist society solar farm
requires 400 times more land and natural
gas plant or a nuclear plant because of
the physics of sunlight or wind I mean
there's you know it's just there's just
nothing but well the solar panels have
become 2 percent or 10 percent more
efficient ok so then it'll be just 360
times more land there's no and that's by
the way that's it's actually been 2
percent efficiency improving over 10
years 10 so you're talking about so and
then there's the unreliability of it you
know you have to have reliable power for
it to be cheap power every time you're
removing electricity out of the grid
into a battery or something else in the
back end you're getting two energy
conversions so the renewables you know
they're doing a lot of work for people
renewables are doing the work for
Malthusian of trying to at least a
fantasy of moving to a low energy
society they're they're obviously a
place that do look at crony capitalist
can make a lot of money just subsidy
farming and then and then they're
providing this spiritual fantasy of
harmonizing human societies with nature
which is the whole point so renewables
just a sight you know renewable
and organics and and humans are now
making themselves right by nature in the
same way that Christians wanted to make
themselves right by God and so it's a
new morality anybody that opposes
renewables is immoral right and and and
satanic in some sense and nuclear itself
is kind of satanic it plays the satanic
role in this new cosmology which is so
powerful because it's so unconscious so
part of the reason I want to write
apocalypse never was just uh let's just
make it conscious and just kind of go if
you want to justify your religion fine
but then I think you need to explain to
everybody why it's worth the devastating
impact it has on the natural environment
why it's worth the big cost increases
the increases that it forces in the
electricity system because often what
riddles are doing is they're
externalizing their cost the unreliable
managing the radical unreliability of
wind turbines only it's a 5 a.m. or 4
a.m. and all this energy is on the grid
you have to pay people to take it like
it's not like this is not great energy
it's often producing large amounts of
garbage energy so you know you kind of
go at the bottom you can do how you know
what could possibly allow such terrible
energy to be viewed as something so good
right only a religion could perform that
right do you find a and obviously you
have you know throughout your career you
engage mostly you know environmentalist
some people like that our people
receptive are you know hardcore greens
receptive to being told you are in the
throes of a religion that you can't even
see because you're so deep into it what
do you think yeah well I I you know I
guess the question is because we live in
a world where you know we have the the
Democratic Party of basically every one
of their presidential candidates had
signed on to some version of the green
New Deal or at least paid lip service to
it you know in an environmental I mean
in in in a profound way I think we are
all environmentalists now in the sense
that we we think about the costs and
benefits of choices of energy choices
and I'm old enough to remember
the public service ads to treat that you
know to teach people not to just throw
garbage out the window of a car on a
highway I mean we had to work we all
think in environmental terms if you know
in terms of cost-benefit to the
surrounding areas but where it looks
like we're about to make a great leap
forward into a very extreme version of
it so how do you you know how do you
what is what is the target audience I
guess in a way for your book is it to
get hard-core greens to you know kind of
change the way they're thinking is it to
get I mean there's a sizable group of
people including in the Republican Party
who are like nothing is wrong that can't
be fixed by just you know dumping crude
oil everywhere you know I mean who had
it how do you convert people to what
your position is which strikes me as
like eminently sensible so I mean part
of the I mean I wrote this book for so
many different audiences I mean I
definitely had conservatives on my mind
while I was writing it I definitely had
progressed this on my mind for writing
it they should be getting different
things out of it if it's working so for
conservatives I think the most important
thing to do is to just get grounded you
really do get grounded in the science
there's still a lot of guys out there on
the right who think that they're either
the plants not really warming or that
carbon dioxide is not as our esteemed
president calls that you know that
climate change is a hoax right it's a
prey right by the Chinese government
somehow in a yeah I don't even want to
try and diagram that yeah that flowchart
but I think it's a kind of a troll
honestly I don't really know that
anybody that says that actually believes
that there's definitely some sunspots
people but you know I testified in front
of the House Committee on Science Space
and Technology and in January and like
not a single Republican was a climate
denier you know and they were all asking
questions and they had other concerns
but it wasn't this kind of the old
caricature and certainly Trump obviously
is responsible for some of that so but
the old character I don't find is true
among like most Republicans you know I
think that they didn't I think miserable
didn't know I talk a little bit about
how as here only came all to Z and the
right actually became ante Malthusian
even though Malthus is truly a
conservative in just the kind of true
conservative sense and why that was and
so I think that there's an sort of the
same reason libertarians ended up on the
right I think in United States so I
think that there's a you know so I think
they're sort of like it just kind of
reject all that because look the IPCC
saw IPCC science it's like fine IPCC
policy recommendations are stupid and
just reflect the green agenda and we
should criticize them I'm actually a
review or I criticized them recently but
I think if the conservatives were to
actually get a more scientific view on
climate change and to adopt this more
humanistic view that I'm proposing which
says look it's not like you're ever
satisfied with your energy source just
like you're never satisfied with your
food production you always want to
improve it but the key is to be going in
the direction of higher power densities
not in the direction of lower power
densities because that requires more
nature more material more mat or more
natural environment must be grounded up
to produce either electricity or food or
products or whatever and Republicans I
think have been articulating they've
been sort of articulating something
close but it's been around the economy
and therefore they've ended up
reinforcing the sense there's some
there's some there's some necessary
[Music]
trade-off between the economy in the
environment but the truth is like France
75% nuclear it's not poor because it has
75 percent nuclear I think you could
actually argue that it's rich so I think
that there's been a confusion on this I
want to write this book for
conservatives and Republicans and the
Rotarians okay so then and then for
progressives obviously yeah
well talk a bit though how quick just on
progressives it's just getting similarly
it's getting to the energy power yeah
yeah it's is the progressives it's just
going also simply getting your head
screwed on right with the science and
being like renewables are problems
because of low power densities and this
is just nothing
to do with capitalism or the man or
whatever or like that's just a problem
with your fuels do you and that actually
yeah that you would you have a sense it
seems you mentioned you're a Gen X or
I'm a late baby boomer and your argument
makes perfect sense to me and I suspect
to a lot of Gen Xers for Millennials Gen
Z younger Americans the environment
regularly shows up and kind of polls and
surveys as a very high order principle
and kind of moving towards a you know
fully renewable posts carbon kind of
energy future why do you think that is
and how do you reach younger people of
whatever kind of ideological orientation
I mean look it's a religion I mean it's
just a complete we're in a total
religious revival it's supposedly
secular but I think I look at I don't
work on race but I listened to John
McWhorter and you know John McWhorter
was doing one of his things with Glenn
Lowry and I think I saw you interview
Quinn Lowry and and I think McWhorter
goes McWhorter goes I'm gonna he's gonna
write a book on how anti racism is the
new religion that was like I was like I
just I just did that on the environment
and it's like it's like I haven't I
haven't spent any time trying figure out
how they kind of work together but it's
like the same people that are in the
street around anti racism run this food
around climate apocalypse so I mean I
think you know the death of God
secularization you so first of all
people need something to believe in you
know that includes like some view of
their own immortality and that's okay
there's nothing wrong with that that's
actually I think it's part of being
human you know the argument I make is
actually our awareness of our mortality
creates anxiety that then this is I'm
taking this from a major anthropologist
who wrote on this makes us want to have
some kind of legacy that's natural
that's okay makes us want to feel heroic
that's great be aware of it
don't you know pretend like you don't
need that or want that and then and then
I think you need a new morality this
whole thing of the obsession with
plastic straws you know the I'm
vegetarian
I showed these things are of no
can I ask you bi I try to eat vegan and
I do that mostly for calories not for
ethical reasons but you have a stat in
the in the book which put me back on my
heels it's that if everybody adopted a
vegetarian diet how much how much of the
earth would that say from farming
it's basically Oh from the where I'm
sorry what what is that what is the
metric yeah I mean carbon emissions it's
it's two to four percent right so
nothing yeah it's just nothing you
should side you should not and only that
but like there's AI can explain why I
basically like does it doesn't even work
out that if you became vegetarian you
could sort of be like there's more will
for this because there's less pasture
the big thing on and how much land we
use for me it's just weather are you
spreading your cows all over the
hillsides like Michael Pollan and the
organicist want us to do
or are you confining them in the evil
industrial farming way because the evil
industrial farming way leaves more of
the earth to the natural environments
obviously okay like just I don't need to
provide any math I mean just think about
you concentrate a hundred cows over a
hundred miles of land versus you know
one mile I mean not you know one of the
things that I really appreciate about
the book too is that you're not just you
know picking off you know certain things
for your argument I mean you talked
about how there is a massive
reforestation of the planet which is a
good thing you know we have more plants
more trees less land is being used for
food production and energy production
and things like that but then that there
are also problems with kind of forests
that are planted by you know people who
are creating timber for us right I mean
yeah everybody knows that an old-growth
forest is just have you ever been in an
old-growth forest it's like it's like
for me it's one of my peak spiritual
existential peak experiences old-growth
redwood forests or old with oak forest
you feel they feel different they feel
like you're in a Cathedral if you're in
some tree farm so I point out yeah
there's reforestation but it's not
exactly mess it's not what you there's
real law
send me Amazon the bigger dynamic is
that by promoting bad forms of
Agriculture Greenpeace has encouraged
fragmentation of the primary forest
primary old-growth forest which we need
if you're gonna have like big cat
species that can move around hundreds of
kilometres of space you need these big
apex predators and so they fragmented it
because they actually thought that there
was something wrong with concentrated
industrialized intensified agriculture
when that's the key that's the one of
that's the most important thing when it
comes to saving the natural environment
what we call the natural primary
conservation
it's concentrating animal production
concentrating food production
intensifying production more food on
less land it's just obvious it's physics
you know there's no advanced physics
it's just simple when you think about it
and yet the dogmatism and the
religiosity then has resulted in real
ecological harm not just harm to people
could you I want to get to uh I want to
hear you make the best case possible for
a nuclear power ubiquitous nuclear power
in a second but just as a specific point
you would mention this in passing about
how the you know the next or the sixth
extinction is not going to happen it's
not happening this is something that we
hear a lot it's like plastic straws you
know killing all sorts of sea life you
know the these are the kind of talking
points or aphorisms of the of the
environmentalist movement what is going
on with extinctions and why should we
not be overly concerned right now that
you know we're going to wake up you know
by the fall
most of our species are going to be
extinct let me tell you what we should
first be concerned about now so you
should about we should just be concerned
that humans have a large footprint we
take up a lot of the earth there's just
not as much habitat for endangered
species as we would want poverty in
particular often drives people into
forested or grassland areas converts
them into farming or ranching and that
is how you get loss of habitat it's also
how you get wild animal consumption so
that's what you want to worry about
extinction because it's such a powerful
word is used by scientists advanced
look relations and advocacy for their
conservation agenda the problem is that
we're not in the sixth mass extinction
we would be I mean you'd have to be the
amount the the share of extinctions has
to be enormous we're just at a very tiny
and it's you know and yeah actually
people don't realize is that what
happened was the way they construct this
is they model they create these models
where they assume a certain amount of
loss of habitat would lead to a certain
number of extinctions well they were
wrong the models always overestimated
extinctions just turns out species are
actually many animal and plant another
species or just good at occupying less
and less land it's kind of sad actually
I mean it's kind of amazing as well but
it's not like extinction is like in
other words we're really good at
maintaining a lot of species diversity
even if you just don't have you know
enough I think for me half of all wild
animals we have half the number of wild
animals in the world today that we had
in 1960 that's the issue if you just
care about wild animals and you want
more wild animals that's too bad we
should have been eating cows and pigs
and chickens instead of eating all those
animals and taking their habitat so
that's why the extinction and then the
other problem of the extinction stuff is
that it's very it's just very
apocalyptic like if you kind of I quote
this conservation science as soon as if
you believe all that sixth extinction
stuff then why would you bother you know
like why would you bother saving things
it's wrong and stupid one of the things
I'm I did in this book very deliberately
very carefully is I got the key
scientists on the phone that often make
these apocalyptic claims I interviewed
them like a proper reporter would which
amazingly no environment reporters had
done before me and basically got them on
the record admitting that you know I
fear they were bullshitting basically or
grossly exaggerating you know or in the
case of the species extinctions one I
just got some of the main scientists
just go on the record and just be like
no you're right we're not in a sixth
extinction so I was like okay then why
why did you guys tell everybody that for
like the last 10 guided years you know
well how you know from up from a lay
position you know and we live in it both
simultaneously and I guess these things
are related in age of experts
and an absolute loss of faith in experts
confidence in experts and institutions
what are the tells that you're being
sold a line of BS on environmental
claims you you spend a fair amount of
time in the book and it's it's it makes
for good reading but it's infuriating
looking at the tactics and the claims of
the grip extinction rebellion in which
is primarily are very big in England but
how do you know when people are kind of
stretching for for true claims well I
mean this book i mean i mean i don't i
think that someone look at things like
health care you know as like complicated
i look at energy the environment is not
that complicated
i mean in some ways you just go those
things i mentioned you know declining
death tolls you know from natural
disasters someone starts talking about
people dying any number millions or
billions you have to be like what is the
mechanism for that what is the mechanism
like how will those people die oh well
we might run out of food well actually
it turns out most everybody agrees that
that as long as the four countries using
fertilizer irrigation tractors and have
roads we're gonna produce much more food
than we produced today we produced 25
percent more food than we need obesity
is a problem we have we we throw away
huge amounts of food that's great man
some ways it's great it's terrible the
waste but it is kind of a sign that
we're secure and wealthy and that that's
not the issue so you know and then in
terms of like this story about energy
moving from lower energy densities both
on energy and food production as well as
well as cities by the way power
densities increases like down it like
Manhattan is like insanely high power
density Singapore right hi Parkinson's
these little rural parts of Congo super
low so just understanding that and that
energy substitutes for matter that you
can leave the natural environment by
using more energy to protect it to save
it I think these things once people get
that framework this is like the last I'm
not gonna doing the book on the
environment over decided like I just got
other things I want to do all right
other articles but like this book
actually there's a secretly I've hidden
an environmental studies textbook in
this book it has all of the science it
has the basic framework that you should
get in your environment
textbook and are not getting so I do
feel like once you read this book your
brain will be able to detect the
[ __ ]
okay well let's here let's try it out
and see if I can detect [ __ ] from
you when you talk about nuclear power
and you know we talked a bit about how
okay you know the nuclear age is born in
you know Hiroshi Amma at Nagasaki the
mushroom cloud that's terrifying and
then you know we still have God knows
where more than enough nuclear weapons
to blow up the planet a million times
over and all of that we have nuclear
power in parts of the world France
overwhelmingly you know generates its
own electricity by that places like
Japan places like Russia but you know
then the history of nuclear power seems
to be littered with these warning signs
these blips or more than blips Fukushima
Chernobyl Three Mile Island which not in
the same league I guess but why should
we be moving towards nuclear you know
and and and also then is it actually
affordable in in any kind of meaningful
what I mean I think the first thing you
have to understand about nuclear you
have to appreciate what it is it is a
revolutionary moment in human evolution
it's a completely radical new technology
okay it is and we knew it would be like
literally before it was invented in the
early 1900s before they had even split
the atom
there was books describing how once we
got nuclear energy it would both open up
the possibility of super bombs huge
bombs and limitless energy basically
limitless clean energy they didn't quite
use that word but that was where they
were talking about so this first thing
is you get it at the lab level I mean
this is the Manhattan Project require
did this huge only the US government
could have done with massive wartime
mobilization but splitting the atom
happens in the lab I mean that's just an
a literally as soon as the word gets out
they did it they replicate it everybody
replicates it in the lab around the
world so this is not something where you
can just kind of be like like smallpox
where you can be like well okay well
some small pox in a couple of freezers
in the United States and Russia like
this is this is comes right out of human
knowledge so what that what that means
is so first of all I mean one of these
so interesting I discovered in the
research for apocalypse never was like
really right after the bomb this group
of scholars at yeah ill and some guys
from Harvard to me figured out right
away what it would mean in fact Niels
Bohr the Nobel prize-winning Danish
physicist who visits Manhattan Project
sees Oppenheimer goes up Tommen is like
this is going to change everything this
is going to end war I mean like
literally they really he's gonna end
work and then they were and then it
freaked them out because of what it
meant for it to end war and so there was
some backpedaling and how do we control
it and whatever they basically long
story short by it was clear that this
weapon is truly terrifying and in and in
fact that's how it works if it wasn't so
terrifying it wouldn't be creating peace
between India China India Pakistan right
you know and other countries Soviet so
in the industrial and the Chinese and
whatever so it's that so but that's the
but that is so kind of horrible in the
sense that that was what like I remember
telling you a friend of mine who's
progressive very much a UN type you know
and she and I was like what just sounds
like you just it just upsets you that
this is how what it took to kind of tame
the human beast she was like yeah it's
horrible like it was supposed to happen
through brotherly love and reason and it
was consoled that whole idea so that's
why that was you that's the weaponry
then how do we you know make the case
for as as the best power source for the
future so so then you get to the energy
and it was obvious to everybody that it
was gonna be the best form of energy
like just because of all the reasons we
know now the high power densities the
fact that there's no air and water
pollution the fact that the so-called
waste is just these used fuel rods that
can be stored on-site tiny quantities of
which never heard anybody never will
hurt anybody that was all that and there
was almost a mannequin thews II Azzam
for nuclear energy in the 50s in part I
think as a kind
like way to make this terrifying new
reality more palatable but that then
didn't last very long and animal food
instructor after nuclear the the the
Quakers and Mennonites and pacifist and
others are going after nuclear weapons
and then it eventually just displaces
itself on to nuclear energy both
deliberately and and through concerted
political action and then so your
questions and it's all my way of getting
your question the accidents whatever
first of all it be like saying like when
you kind of go well I don't know
chemistry you know chemistry look at all
the accidents with chemistry and it's
kind of like if there's a new whole new
field of science which is what nuclear a
whole new field aside a whole new
industrial capacity like I kinda go well
of course there's gonna be a shitload of
accidents like you're kind of like I'm
kind of amazed there haven't been more
and if they haven't been worse and
that's what we keep finding at point out
basically the radiation at a stage from
these accidents just not the super
potent toxin that people imagine there's
not very much of it because of the high
power densities meaning that it's just
you know nuclear fuel rods you know as
opposed to coal and wood you're just
putting a lot of material particulate
matter into the environment very little
of that escapes from nuclear so I go the
overreaction to those accidents is
displacement you know it's one of the
one of the reactors melted it like Three
Mile Island it's like wow okay yeah
that's and there's that kind of we knew
that would happen and it was like you
know as a first generation and then like
and so I mean people were killed in this
major industrial accident Oh nobody so
ok Fukushima operation there Oh nobody
chernobyl II kind of dig down into it at
best you can kind of count 200 dead
bodies over like an 80 year period so
you so ultimately nothing if you believe
that science and I document all in the
book I have the best expert on it then
something else is going on and clearly
the bomb is a big part of that now it's
again it's more progressive than
conservatives who are worried about
nuclear it's more women and then you
know so there's other things going on
there but
but nonetheless I think that's the big
animating factor that freaks us out
about technology
my understanding of nuclear plants in
the United States at the very least and
I I think this may be true in Europe as
well as that they really once they're up
and running if you can assume a plant
has been built and is running it's
incredibly cost-effective compared to
you know carbon or you know oil gas
things like that but that it actually it
takes an enormous amount of subsidies to
put a plant in operation is that
accurate or how would you how would you
address that no it's not they're not
subsidies there are I mean I guess you
could argue that you know loan
guarantees are a subsidy but it doesn't
have to be with subsidies it can also
just be you know under the traditional
regulated public utility model where you
have a natural monopoly in the form of
electrical electrical electric company
because you don't want you know more
than 100 electric companies stringing up
wires everywhere it's a natural monopoly
we said we're gonna either have it's
either gonna be socialist 30 percent of
of us electricity is socialist basically
publicly owned utilities seventy percent
is privately owned it's similar to that
in Japan but South Korea France and many
other countries are just publicly owned
utilities and so when they invest
they'll just though they they don't
usually need a subsidy they usually just
need to be able to start charging for
some of that electricity in advance in
order to make the capital that they
borrowed cheaper so the most important
thing is that you have cheap capital but
it's like what you said I mean it's like
if you think that this is important to
the civilization and again I don't I'm
not suggesting that if we don't do it
that this civilization is in threat from
climate change I've actually just sort
of criticizing that nonetheless if you
think like and there's that nuclear is
something that you need for civilization
it's just like building a bridge or a
highway or a stadium or anything like
that and there's cost overruns just like
there are with those things you expand
the subway you do the Big Dig in Boston
you do the high-speed rail and
and those things have cost overruns but
there's no need for you know unless it's
a you know what it would basically
happened was with deregulation and it
made it harder to be able to do the kind
of investments that we did was nuclear
in the 1970s but we're still able to it
just we don't really have weirdoes not
really set up right to do it I guess as
a closing thought are you optimistic
that that the kind of high-water mark
I'm reaching for bad metaphors here
high-water mark fever you know the high
you know high fever whatever of kind of
environmental alarmism are we
is that cresting or do you see that
cresting sometime soon how optimistic
are you that the message that you're
putting out in your book
apocalypse never is going to carry the
day I mean I think after apocalypse
never and some of the stuff that we're
gonna do to call out the really bad
science I think it's gonna be
increasingly hard to claim that climate
change is causing natural disasters that
it will increase deaths from natural
disasters in the future I think that
climate change will eventually have the
same trajectory as fears of
overpopulation and had which is that it
will continue to sort of be something
that people say and talk about but it
won't have the kind of it won't be what
a OS the next a OC is crusading on I do
think the left will keep coming around
on nuclear I just hired Zion lights from
extinction rebellion who's the person
that is in the book to help us to build
nuclear plants in Britain but I think
the point I would make is that until
there's some alternative religion until
there's like some national I mean
whether it's nationalism or socialism or
some alternative to the traditional
judeo-christianity people are gonna keep
finding new religions because we need
that so I mean for me the question is
what would the alternative religion I
mean I mean I would argue in some sense
libertarian is a kind of you know
spiritual existential moral worldview
what I'm proposing environmental
humanism is the same but I do think that
in some ways there's just the work of
Sisyphus that we do have to keep
you know confronting apocalyptic
millenarian ideologies because they are
harmful I mean they're causing things
they're contributing to anxiety and
depression and people it's being used as
a strategy to basically keep poor
countries from accessing cheap energy
and thus economic growth so for me it's
more like I don't know I can't tell you
exactly how big our victory will be but
I do think the work is essential and
you've got to kind of push back on this
stuff so it doesn't cause the kind of
harm that it's been causing in recent
years I'm thinking with the myth of
sisyphus if we could only harness the
energy of that boulder rolling down the
hill every night we yeah we wish it
would carbon right yeah right right
we'll leave it there the book is
apocalypse never why environmental
alarmism hurts us all the author is
Michael Shellenberger Mike thanks so
much for talking to reason thanks for
having me Nick good to see you
[Music]